Якщо подивитися на окоренок цього дуба, то ви бачите, що в ньому, по-перше,
гниль, яка вже випала повністю. Дірочки - це різні шкідники короїди.
Ну, а ці сині плями говорять про те, що у певний період тут проходили великі бої,
і це залишки, осколки по всьому стовбурі.
Директор Інституту лісового і садово-паркового господарства
Національного університету біоресурсів і природокористування Петро Лакида
показує один із 17 свіжозрізаних віковічних дубів,
через які вже тиждень не вщухають дискусії і перевірки навчального закладу.
Скандал розгорівся після того, як в одній із спільнот у "Фейсбуці"
опублікували інформацію про те, що в Голосіївському парку знищили
старі дуби, які мали охоронний статус.
У НУБіП запевняють: пост містив фейкові фотографії,
а дерева не були під захистом, і зрізали їх цілком легально.
У 2018 незалежна комісія, яка включала в себе і Мінекології,
і Зеленбуд, і один наш фахівець, обійшли, подивилися, вибрали ті дерева,
які сухі стоять вже десяток років і становлять певну небезпеку
для оточуючого середовища, для людей передовсім. Тому що у нас
тут дитячий садочок, ось поруч ми проїздили школу,
ну, і 15 тисяч студентів НУБІП, які тут проходять практику і навчаються.
Через розголос цього випадку прокуратура розпочала кримінальне провадження
за фактом вирубки вікових дубів у Голосіївському парку.
Утім, зрізання дерев - не найбільша проблема Києва.
Куди частіше у столиці та й в інших українських містах можна зустріти
ще живі, але зовсім обезкронені насадження.
Це наслідки так званого топінгу, тобто зрізання крони дерев.
Через смертельну шкоду такого методу для деяких порід дерев,
міста накладають мораторій на такі дії. Зараз він запроваджений у Львові та Дніпрі.
У Києві термін заборони вже сплив після 2 років дії,
і дерева знову почали обезкронювати. Комунальники запевняють:
топінг деревам не шкодить, а допомагає.
Кронування стосувалося видалення омели, тому що омела
- це паразит.
Ми бачимо тільки їхні шапочки, зелену масу,
а коріння омели йде на 15-20 метрів по стовбуру дерева.
Для того, щоб хоч якось її видалити, ми повинні зробити певні роботи,
тобто понизити стовбур на якусь певну висоту.
Полярдинг, топінг – це нормально. Це треба постійно робити.
На практиці крони і гілки дерев доволі часто радикально обрізають
без вагомих на те причин. Відтак в українських містах замість затінених зелених алей
з’являються ряди чорних стовбурів.
Засновниця громадської організації "Місто-сад" і депутатка Київради Євгенія Кулеба
каже, що дедалі частіше отримує скарги від киян на нещадне
поводження з деревами з боку як комунальників, так і бізнесу чи окремих жителів.
Однозначно догляд не може бути покладений
за деревами на балансоутримувачів територій, на їхні смаки,
їхні вподобання і на їхню оцінку того, що потрібно, наприклад,
здійснювати омолоджувальну обрізку, яку взагалі в Європі вже ніхто не робить, чи ні.
Усім мають займатися спеціалісти. Не може людина без спеціальної освіти
ухвалювати рішення, старе це дерево чи не старе. Тим більше будь-яке старе дерево
треба оглянути і, можливо, лікувати. Не обов’язково зрізати під пеньок дерево,
якщо є можливість. Навіть тут ось ми знаходимося у сквері,
і наскільки я знаю, тут є дерева, які громада буде
намагатися рятувати і лікувати.
Професійний дендролог Ігор Куземко переконаний: загроза від неправильного
поводження з деревами в Україні дуже недооцінена. А застосування
топінгу без врахування особливостей породи несе загрозу
не тільки деревам, але насамперед і людям.
Проблема полягає в тому, що обрізка дерев - топінг -
йде абсолютно без урахувань видового складу.
Є породи дерев, які спокійно переносять обрізку, їх можна обрізати,
їх можна кронувати в кулевидну форму чи будь-яку іншу.
Наприклад, липа або тополя обростає, хоча й повільно. А обрізається все
по шаблону абсолютно, залишається лише стовбур, берези, клени,
тобто дерево повільно гине. У мене особисто виникає питання, для чого це робиться,
тобто міські насадження зелені - їхня функція яка?
Поглинання вуглецю, шкідливих викидів, автомобілів і пилозахист.
Саме тополя пірамідальна, мабуть, найкраще дерево
з точки зору переробки вуглецю. Коли тут недалеко, до речі, обрізали
пірамідальні тополі, воно-то, звичайно, пообростає, але це займає дуже багато часу.
В цей час дерево не виконує ту функцію, заради якої його садили 50-60 років тому.
Дендрологи закликають докладати максимум зусиль для порятунку старих дерев.
Адже нові насадження не можуть стати повноцінною компенсацією
природі за вже зрубані зрілі дерева.
Зараз проблема така, що зміни клімату призвели до того, що
навіть ті аборигенні дерева, які ви ось тут бачите,
наприклад, дуби, вони вже, якщо їх зараз посадити, навряд чи досягнуть
ось такого хабітасу, от такого вигляду, як вони є зараз, коли 80-100 років такому дереву.
У Києві вже створили робочу групу, яка має на меті врегулювати
сферу поводження із зеленими насадженнями.
Ми будемо напрацьовувати положення щодо догляду за кроною.
На державному рівні також потрібно це питання врегулювати,
тому що наразі обрізка відбувається на підставі наказу про благоустрій,
який вже морально застарів і не відповідає європейським нормам.
Має бути професійна оцінка. І на підставі цієї професійної оцінки підготовлені акти,
а на підставі актів - здійснюватися догляд за кронами. А взагалі у нас
є велика мрія. Ми хочемо принаймні в Києві створити карту дерев,
на якій будуть зафіксовані всі дерева, їхній стан, потреба у догляді,
все буде фіксуватися і не можна буде просто прийти й зрізати дерево.
А поки Євгенія Кулеба радить усім українцям
робити усе можливе для порятунку дерев.
Якщо ви бачите, що відбувається догляд за деревом, можна підійти, запитати акт.
Якщо актів немає, то також є алгоритм. Можна робити фотофіксацію
як дерев, так і людей, їхніх машин, викликати поліцію
саме для фіксації можливого правопорушення.
Потім можна звертатися до державної екоінспекції й управління благоустрою.
На державному рівні одним із способів порятунку зелених насаджень
вважають посилення покарання за рубку дерев чи кущів у населених пунктах.
Верховна Рада вже підтримала у першому читанні підняття штрафів удесятеро.
За умисне пошкодження дерев чи чагарників, яке завдало істотної шкоди,
порушників хочуть штрафувати на 17000 грн,
а в деяких випадках навіть позбавляти волі на три роки.